- Yeah, hi everyone, I'm Kathryn.
I use she/her pronouns
and I am a
third year PhD student at Rockefeller.
So I've done the high school, college,
and now I'm going to
try and get a doctorate,
if the bacteria let me.
And yeah, I'm in a lab
that studies microbiology.
We actually study the bacteria
that causes the disease tuberculosis.
I think it's really interesting.
And today we're gonna talk about PCR,
a little bit about gel electrophoresis
and why we might want to do
those different things in lab
and in other applications like forensics
and paternity testing.
But just to kind of ease
everybody into the Zoom session,
I'm gonna start a poll as an icebreaker.
So let me know what
your favorite season is.
Throughout the lesson,
I'll be asking questions
just to see how everyone's
following
and if there's anything
that I'm not saying clearly,
just interrupt me.
If you have any questions,
totally interrupt me
but we'll also like leave time for that.
Yeah.
So we're doing pretty
good on the poll so far.
We're just,
I think the person who
has not voted is my phone.
So yeah, I have to remind myself
that we're only ever gonna get
to one minus the total number
because I'm not gonna answer my own poll.
Yeah, so, a couple more people came in,
just wanted to say hi, I'm Kathryn.
And when you get the chance,
you can fill out the poll.
But I'll end it in like
20 seconds.
It looks like right
now spring is gonna win
as the class's favorite season.
That's awesome.
My favorite season is
fall, but I'll take it.
Great.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think you guys
can see the results.
Spring has won.
At this point I'm just glad
it's not as cold as it was.
I will stop sharing these results and,
yeah,
now we can get to the
fun part, the science.
So what we're gonna talk about is PCR.
I think you guys have done a
little bit of reading on it
but just to kind of get things
going like a cooking show,
we're gonna start something.
We're gonna start loading the gel,
which we'll talk about a little later
because it takes a little bit of time.
And this way we can kind of go
through some of the other
steps I did last night
to prep for this.
But we wanna start with something fun
and I'm just putting on gloves.
I do the little spin thing,
so I don't have to touch it.
And let me know if you can see
the video from my phone.
If anything's not clear,
let me know.
Oh, thank you for spotlighting
the video Odaelys.
Yeah, so,
these are our samples.
We've labeled them A, B and C
and they're in these really
cute, really small tubes.
And you can see that
they're like totally clear.
They're just liquid.
And these ones are really small
but they hold like 50 microliters.
So micro is 10
to the minus six.
So this is like teeny tiny volumes.
And we have just kind
of cool bigger tubes.
This one has water.
This one has nothing
in it, but it's green.
So I wanna use this later because
I think it's a good color.
So the first thing we're
gonna do is put our samples
in this gel that I need.
So, a gel
is made of agarose,
basically it's a polymer.
So it's made up of several
units and it's like jello.
So you watch, I can poke it.
And like, it's quite a hard
one, it's a high percentage.
And we talk about gels as a
percent of the total volume.
And we have these little cones in here
that lets us make wells where
we can load our samples.
So I'm just pulling out the cone
and then we'll take it
out of this little tray
where we make it, one second.
And I can get this out with.
So sorry y'all, I'm gonna put
you like that for a second.
Yeah.
Yeah, we have this fun panel,
looks like a piece of jello.
And in this you have a
chemical called indium bromide.
Basically it stains DNA.
So when we put DNA in these wells,
we'll be able to see it by
imaging.
So to start, we're gonna
actually walk with our gel
to the box where we put
it in for electrophoresis.
We use electricity to move the DNA.
So I'm not sure if you all know,
the charge of DNA is negative
because of the phosphate backbones.
I'm gonna leave you over here for a second
while I pour some stuff.
Yeah, the phosphate backbone
of DNA makes it negative.
So,
negative charges like
should be really far away
from other negative charges.
Negative charges are
attracted to positives.
The whole positive attract kind of thing.
I actually can't see if we can see this.
So we put the gel in
and we add what's essentially
salty water around it
so that the electricity can be conducted
because regular water isn't
that good of a conductor.
So on the back side, we'll
apply a negative charge.
And ours actually even has a little,
it's hard to see, negative sign
there, so you don't forget.
And on the red side, we
have a positive charge
and we'll put DNA right at
the top in these little wells.
And negative DNA will move
away from the negative well,
and it will,
sorry.
And it'll move down to the positive well.
And you can think of it kind of like
you're trying to move in a sea of people.
If you are like really,
really tall at a concert,
it can be really hard to move
when there's a lot of people.
But if you're really short at a concert,
you can move really easily
through a tight group of people.
And it's the same thing with the DNA.
If the DNA is really big in size,
it has trouble moving through the agarose,
so it'll get stuck up at the top.
But the really small pieces
can move quite easily,
so it'll go down.
So let's grab our samples.
I'm gonna leave you here for one moment,
don't touch anything.
Cool, now I checked
chat while it was there,
everything is going okay so far.
So,
we have now,
our samples are clear.
So if I put them in here,
I won't be able to see
how far they've moved
and then I don't know when to stop it.
So what we do is we add this purple dye.
Oops, sorry, it wasn't in the frame.
And it just lets us see
how far things are moving,
so we know when to stop it.
We also have,
yes, ladder.
Oh yes.
As your instructor said,
you can post any questions
you have in the chat.
You can stop me.
I love talking about this,
so you can just go ahead
with whatever you'd like.
We have this marker and it's
already got the dye in it.
And this has pieces of DNA
that we know the size of.
So we know that the biggest
piece should be at the top
and the smallest piece
should be at the bottom.
And this lets us see about
how big is this piece of DNA
that I've made.
So if it runs in between something that is
units and 400 units,
I can say, okay, my piece
is probably 300 units.
So, just real quick, doing
the cooking show thing.
First we will add some of that
purple dye to our samples.
Just rest y'all.
Sorry.
Can y'all see that okay?
Thanks everyone.
Thanks.
So we'll add some of
our dye into our samples
with a pipette.
So the pipette lets us
measure really small volumes
and, I dropped you.
Thanks for bearing with me
while I kind of get myself situated.
Okay, that'll work.
Yeah, so Odaelys has
asked if anyone's used
a micro pipette before?
Awesome, not some of you have done so.
They're really fun in my opinion.
So we'll shake everything and
then add a little bit to each.
Sorry, I almost didn't adjust it.
So hard to see but I'm
just turning the top,
so get it to the volume I want.
So I want this number to be 10
and I'm gonna add 10, this
is microliters to each.
I'm just popping it into the side.
You can see the purple
kind of just slide down
'cause it's really thick
and this helps weigh down
our sample and our DNA.
Sorry, I dropped you again.
So what we're gonna do is add
these into the little wells
and like, Odaelys from
RockEDU was saying hopefully
when the pandemic's over
y'all can come to campus
and do this yourself
'cause it's really fun.
Then were gonna take,
oh, I should've mixed that too.
I'm gonna hang up my pipette,
put the lid back on this,
mix, mix, mix, mix, mix.
And we'll add a little bit
of this to the first well,
so that as the ladder runs,
I can see about how big
my pieces are.
So, this is the tricky part
and it's gonna be extra tricky
because now I'm also holding a cell phone.
So we're gonna find the well with the tip
and I kind of wiggle it to make sure
that I'm in the right
spot and then I eject.
Basically I'm pressing down at the top.
Now we have green sample in that well.
Super cool, sinks to the bottom, all good.
Now we're gonna do the same
thing with our unknown samples
which I'll talk a little bit
more about while this runs.
I'm just changing the
volume, spinning the top.
I want it to be the biggest
volume it'll let me, perfect.
I'm gonna take my first sample
and I go up and down to mix it.
I'm gonna say, okay, I'm
trying to get it in that well,
and I eject it at the bottom.
And I wasn't able to get
all of the sample at once,
so I went back to pull it up
and I'll put it in the exact same well.
You can see some of it kind
of floating out on the top.
I can do that again over there.
That just means that it was
more than the well could hold.
Totally fine.
We'll do the same thing
with the next sample.
This actually took me quite
a while to get good at.
The first couple of times I did this,
I like punctured it and
I lost a bunch of sample
and it was super annoying.
But now I'd like to think I'm pretty good.
We'll load the final sample
and then we can talk while this runs.
Ooh, so sorry, I'm getting
a spam call, hold on.
Ah, cool, thank God.
I get a lot of spam calls these days
mostly about car insurance
and I don't have a car, so.
- [Man] It was an emergency alert.
- [Kathryn] Oh, apparently
it was an emergency alert
from campus.
So someone else will let you know.
It's just that our email was down.
- [Man] Okay, that's fair.
- Great, and now we
put on this little top.
This connects our electrodes.
The red and black
edges to a power source.
I'm gonna turn on and match up the colors.
So red always goes to red.
Sorry, I know I lost you all
out of frame for a second.
And we're gonna apply a
current by setting a voltage.
So what we'll do is say,
okay, get it up to like 120
or 130 volts 'cause I want
this to go fast enough
for y'all to see the end.
And we'll run it for
about 15 minutes during
which we'll talk about PCR.
Yeah, 15, 18, it's all the same.
So I hit the run button.
It'll apply a current
and can y'all see those bubbles
coming up from the side?
That's how I know that the
current is going through my box
and through my gel.
So the bubbles are there,
I'm applying a negative
charge on this side.
My negatively charged DNA will be repelled
from the negative current
and attracted to the positive
current on this side.
And the DNA will be separated by size,
just like moving through a concert.
If you're really big,
you get stuck at the top,
if you're really small, you
can move easily to the bottom.
So I'm just gonna leave all
my stuff here for right now.
Bad lab etiquette, but that's fine.
And I'll scoot back over
so we can talk a little bit
while that runs.
So,
I think y'all can see me from the,
oh, there's tape in the way
from the other camera now.
Thank you so much for
making do with the,
moving back and forth
and the kind of cooking aspect
where I've started one thing
and I'm coming back.
So,
yeah, if you have any questions,
anything you wanna chat
about, let me know.
We'll talk a little bit about PCR now.
So what was in those tubes
that we put in the DNA?
Sorry, that we put in the agarose gel?
So,
just as a quick question,
how many of you guys
know what PCR stands for?
So, no penalty if you've
put the wrong answer.
Just, I've launched a poll
of what those PCR stands for?
And I'll give you all
some time to set that up.
I'll grab my notes.
Let's give it like 10, 15 more seconds.
Don't worry about it.
- [Teacher] And this is not
gonna be graded so you can,
you know take a chance.
Of course, you know, I do get a chance
to see how many of you
actually did the assignment
that I asked you to do before the lab.
But you know, it's not like
you're gonna be graded on it.
We just need to know.
So don't be afraid to answer.
Yes, right.
We cannot see who's answering incorrectly,
we just wanna see the number of people.
And you know, to me, it looks pretty good.
I see that most of you
actually did watch the videos
that I ask you to see.
- And I will say I worked very
hard to make these answers
pretty tricky, so perfect.
I will end our poll,
if anyone wants to get
any last minute votes in.
Ready?
Okay.
So sharing the result for y'all.
Yeah, PCR stands for polymerase
chain reaction, perfect.
I understand why you put choice one,
polynomial catalyzed reaction.
Sounds kind of similar, you got poly,
you got like a sciencey words, no problem.
So let's go over why we call
PCR polymerase chain reaction?
Like why does that mean make sense?
So polymerase, if you break
down the roots of the word,
poly, thank you for stopping
sharing the poll, awesome.
Poly means
many.
And,
a polymer is a molecule
made up of many individual pieces.
So,
DNA.
That good model that
Odaelys lent me, thank you,
is a molecule made up of
individual nucleotides.
So each of these colors here,
there's blue, there's red,
we've got orange and green
are different individual monomers.
One piece, monomer.
It looks like I'm in jail.
And they come together to
make a polymer, many pieces.
Ase is the ending we give to an enzyme.
So polymerase means it puts
many individual pieces together.
A chain reaction is just
like it is in physics
where one thing goes to two
things and then each of those
goes to another two, it's an
exponential kind of growth.
So we'll chat a little
bit more about that.
When you're doing PCR, sorry for the,
dealing with this.
We start with one piece of DNA.
And then after one cycle,
we get two pieces of DNA.
And we'll talk about a cycle in a second.
And after two cycles each
of these individual pieces,
goes to another two.
So it's a chain reaction
where one thing goes to two
and then each of those
two goes to another two,
goes to another two.
And we'll do this chemical reaction,
this polymerase chain reaction
like 35 times
to make our samples.
So we end up with a lot of DNA.
So that's what PCR stands for.
And now what's actually happening?
What was in those tubes that
I showed you, our samples?
So can I remember
what was my next poll?
Okay.
So for a PCR reaction,
it's like the baking,
you have a lot of ingredients.
I have to have my very
messy lab notebook here
where I wrote down all of my ingredients,
but my handwriting's bad
so I'm gonna not show you that anymore.
So things that you need for a reaction.
Well, we're trying to
amplify pieces of DNA.
So we need what we're amplifying off of.
We need a template piece of DNA
and that's obviously native DNA.
So you need the template
that we're gonna copy from,
you need the enzyme, the machine
that does the copying
that's called a polymerase.
That's an enzyme, so it's
made out of proteins.
And then you need the monomers,
the each building blocks.
And these are called nucleotides.
So you put all of that in a reaction.
And now you need to know,
the enzyme can't just find
a piece of DNA and be like,
oh, I feel like copying here.
You have to tell it where
it's gonna copy from
and it needs a little
piece to get started.
These are called primers.
And those are synthetic
pieces of DNA that will pop in
and say, okay, this is
where we're gonna start.
So if we skip ahead a little bit,
I'm so sorry that I'm not good at Zoom
and I don't have this
like on a share screen.
- [Jeanne] No, it looks perfect.
- Oh, thank you so much.
So if you see, we start with our template,
let me (indistinct) my face out of that.
And then we're gonna open it up.
We'll talk about that in one moment.
And then these primers, these
little red pieces of DNA
match up by the nucleotide
matchings, A, T, C, G,
that thing.
And it says, okay this is
where we're gonna start
making more DNA.
We're gonna amplify
based on these primers.
So quick poll, just to make sure
that I am explaining this clearly.
What is the reaction template made of?
That's the first piece that we start with.
Y'all are already killing it.
Just giving you some time, but
yeah, don't worry about it,
you can put in whatever you
want, I'm not gonna tell.
Okay, just waiting for
a couple more people.
And,
well, I'm waiting for a couple more people
to just answer.
I will actually put in an answer myself.
I should put in the right answer, okay.
We can check on how our gel's doing.
You can see it's fogging up
'cause it's getting a little bit hot but,
oops!
Our DNA pieces are, our colors
started out right over here
where the wells are and
because of the electricity,
it started to move down.
You can see our purple has
scooted down a fair bit.
We still have like 9,
10 more minutes on this.
So I'm gonna leave it, but
we know it's working so far.
It's always exciting when you
can get something to work.
And I'm gonna close the poll.
So if you have any, thank
you for spotlighting Odaelys,
super helpful.
And I'm gonna share the results.
You guys are superstars.
Yes, the template is made of DNA.
We're amplifying DNA to
make more and more of it.
So we wanna say, okay,
copy this piece of DNA.
Protein was a good guess
but that's what the enzymes
polymerase is made of.
That's the machine that
actually does the copying.
So,
how do you copy DNA?
Well,
we had the DNA in the double helix.
Really cool, everything's
lined up by base pairing.
The nucleotides have a
match with each other.
If we imagine stretching
that out and flattening it,
you can end up with this
where the gray is a phosphate backbone,
it's the back part of the
DNA, a negative charge.
And then these are individual nucleotides.
I have them turn the wrong way
but the blue one actually says C on it,
the green one says G
and then the red is A
and the yellow is T and
this is like super accurate.
They physically pair up like
this and they're quite tight.
Pretend I didn't just do that.
They're quite tight, they hold together.
So the first part of a PCR is
we got to break them apart.
I can't copy this if I can't
read what these matches are.
And you can imagine you're an enzyme,
if you just go like this, like
if you just touch the top,
you don't know what these are.
But if you break them apart you can say,
ah, I know what this piece is.
I have three bumps and it's
short, so I know it's a C.
This one has three bumps, but
it's long so it must be a G.
So the way that we break apart DNA
is called denaturing.
You get it really, really hot
and then all of the pieces come apart.
And it looks just like that
where it separates into the two strands.
And then, like I said, the enzyme,
sorry, balancing a little, can
go in and read these and say,
okay, short three, that must be a C,
long, two, that must be an A,
short, three, that's a C,
short, two, that's a T.
And then it'll go all the way through
and that's how the polymerase
reads what the letters are.
So what we have is a primer,
because if you open all of this up,
how do you know where to start?
So the enzyme doesn't know
what you're trying to amplify,
it just knows, oh, look, there's DNA here.
So you give it a little direction.
You give it a primer that
just like these pieces
bind.
So,
now they're a little piece of DNA,
that binds here and then has this opening.
So you give it a little
headstart of priming
and then it will allow the
polymerase to keep reading
and keep attaching nucleotides.
So the polymerase will go through and say,
ah, yes what pairs with a C?
And it'll go through all
the different nucleotides
and it'll say cheek, and
it'll catalyze that reaction.
It'll go all the way through and then,
you'll make your whole piece
and you'll change the temperature
and you'll start again
'cause it's a chain reaction.
Whereas the product of each
cycle becomes the template,
the starting DNA for the next cycle.
So you get many, many
more pieces over and over.
And I've kind of written
out way you do that,
is we take one piece of DNA,
we get it really hot to denature it,
break the two strands apart.
And then when the primers match up
with their complimentary
basis, that's called annealing.
And that happens at a
slightly lower temperature.
This will actually depend on
the individual nucleotide sequences,
which are these guys right here.
So when I show you the PCR I actually ran,
it'll be a little different,
but still the same.
You get a lower temperature
to kind of help the primer
find its matching spot.
Then you'll go through
extension or elongation
where you add in all of the nucleotides,
this is your actual
amplification reaction.
And then you do this again and
again like 25 to 30 cycles.
And you have a ton of product,
which is what we had in those tubes
that we're running on the
gel to see what we have.
So I had tubes labeled A, B and C.
In one of those tubes, I
didn't put any primers.
So this isn't a poll, but
just if anyone in the chat
or if you wanna unmute yourself,
do you think I'll get a product
if I don't include primers?
If I don't tell the enzyme
where to start amplifying from?
No penalty for wrong answers.
- [Teacher] Yes, you
can type it in the chat.
- Yeah, sorry, I can't see
all of you all at once.
You're awesome, yeah.
There's not gonna be any product.
Ty, if I don't tell the
polymerase where to latch on
and start amplifying from it,
it can't find a piece in the DNA
and it'll just kind of float around there
and you won't get any product
which means you won't
see a band on the gel.
So in one of those three tubes,
I didn't put any primers.
Keep that in mind 'cause
when we run them on the gel
I'm gonna ask you which tube
doesn't have any primers?
You know, that means there's no product,
there won't be a band on the gel.
What other questions did I have?
Ah, cool.
This one, I went over super
quickly, so no problem,
if you didn't catch this.
During what step that you saw here
does the primer bind to the template?
Is it during denaturing,
annealing or extension?
No penalty for wrong answers.
Go ahead, whatever you feel.
I'm gonna put that down
because that is cheating.
But again, no problem, you might as well.
Yeah, awesome, doing so great.
Gonna give it like 10 more seconds.
Just so we can go check on our product.
I'm gonna close the poll
now, but yes, perfect.
Primers bind during the annealing stage.
They come together and
match with the template.
Denaturing which was when we
broke the two strands apart.
Denature is any time you
break apart something.
So you can also denature a protein,
break it up into its amino acid monomers.
When you break apart DNA, you apply heat
and break it up into the strands.
The nucleotides are unmatched
And the extension step
was where we added in
our new nucleotides to
make that amplification.
So after our primer had bound
when we added in each
individual nucleotides
to make even more, that's extending.
This model actually was not
the best way to show that
so I'll pull up this again.
This is from Khan Academy.
So super, super great
resource if you all want it.
We take our primers and we extend
to make more of our target DNA.
Awesome work.
So,
one final question before we
walk over and check our gel.
What does gel electrophoresis
separate DNA pieces by?
Does it separate them by
size, by polarity, by acidity?
So as a hint, remember that analogy I had
where if you're really tall at a concert,
it's hard to move through that thick jelly
of all of those people.
If you're really short though,
you can kind of slide through
everybody quite easily.
Awesome, you're doing super great already.
Let me give you 10 more seconds
but you're on the right track.
Get your final answers in.
Exactly, gel electrophoresis,
that agarose gel separates DNA by size.
I see polarity may have tripped you up
because we talked a lot about
the charge and the electricity
but that charge just
helps you move the DNA.
So DNA because of that phosphate backbone
is negative by putting a
negative charge at the top
and a positive charge at the bottom,
you forced the DNA to move
away from the negative charge.
And then as it's moving big
pieces get stuck in the agarose,
small pieces slide through quite easily.
So by applying an electric charge,
you are able to separate
your pieces by size.
So,
our
gel should be done.
Perfect, our run is complete.
I will remove the lid so
you all can see it easier.
But first, I'm just gonna
steal some of these gloves.
There are different colors.
I like the purple ones 'cause
purple's my favorite color
but you still get the job done.
So if we...
Sorry, I have to put
you down for one moment.
Two handed job to take off the lid.
So, if you remember we put
the DNA in the wells up here
and you'll see, it's
moved quite a bit down.
You can choose to run it longer,
get it all the way down to
the bottom bit of the gel
but we don't need to
do that for right now.
So the way we image these gels,
the type of chemical we put in,
lets us
image them with UV light.
So I'm just picking up my jelly
making sure it doesn't drip on the floor
and let's walk over to
the imagery together.
I'm excited about this.
So we have someone else's gel.
Oh, you can see my
reflection, that's not nice.
I'm just checking that our
imager has the right thing in it.
You'll see indium bromide is something
you can image on this tray.
So,
I am picking up my big jello
laying it on there.
So right now we're just
looking at it like a regular,
there's an air bubble.
I'll just scooch that out.
Nice, little bubble, but
that's not a big deal.
So you can see this, this is
just a regular timer right now.
Can't see anything special,
just the dye bands.
But when we use UV light,
we'll be able to see
bands from all the DNA.
So we should be able to see the ladder
which will look like this one.
You get bands for the
different sizes of DNA
and then we should be
able to see our products.
So let me just turn off the
saturation notification.
Look at how cool that is.
I hate that my reflection is there.
But you can zoom in on this
picture and look at the ladder,
all of the different sizes separated.
So this is the farthest down piece
which means it's the smallest.
I'm so excited that
y'all think this is cool
because every day that
I do this, I'm like,
oh man, that's so cool.
And I've been doing this
for a couple of years now
but it's still so exciting.
So if we track our known marker,
you know that the smallest
piece of DNA I should see
is about 0.5 kilo bases.
So kilo is a thousand
bases is those individual
nucleotide bases.
So 0.5 kilobases
is 500 bases.
That line right up there,
then the next one up should be a thousand.
The one up from there, and
I don't have this memorized,
I look at the second time,
should be 1.5 kilobases.
And I actually calculated ahead of time
this product that we should get
should be about 1.2 kilobases
which is perfect
because it's in between
this one and 1.5 ladder.
1.2 is between those, that's awesome.
And now I'm gonna ask y'all,
I'm gonna run back
actually and get our poll.
- [Odaelys] I can launch the poll for you,
would you like me to do that?
- Oh, that would be
awesome, thank you so much.
And I just got our jelly here.
Pop that out of the tray.
Which one of these reactions
did not have primers in it?
This is our marker, this is empty.
That's just some spill
over from this well.
This is a sample, ooh,
sample A,
sample B
or sample C?
Which one had no primers?
So once again, marker
is an empty sample A,
is an empty sample B, this
is an empty well sample C
and this isn't.
These little bands are just spilled over
because you saw when
ejected into the well,
I kind of got some extra on the outside.
Let me take my stuff back over.
- [Odaelys] Awesome.
So, I give you like
five seconds to answer.
Anyone else wants to answer the poll?
- [Kathryn] Oh, I ripped
the glove again, that's why,
I'm going back to my purple ones
or maybe I'm just really excited.
- [Odaelys] So I'm gonna end the poll.
- Awesome, perfect.
Yeah, sample B.
It didn't have that band,
which means it had no product.
We know that in this case
it's because I didn't
put any primaries in.
I didn't tell the preliminaries
where to amplify from.
So you just kind of got lost
and didn't make anything.
Yeah, I'm super excited
that that worked out.
PCR is one of the bane of my existence.
So sometimes it does not work
even when I plan it super carefully.
Yeah.
If y'all have any questions
about PCR, electrophoresis,
becoming a scientist, going to college,
feel free to pop them in the chat,
you can also unmute yourself.
Maybe while y'all think about questions,
I'll tell you a little
bit about my schooling,
how I got here.
So I'm actually from
Long Island, New York.
I went to high school out there.
Wanted to do science.
Also did not wanna spend
a ton of money on college
so I went to SUNY, Stony
Brook also on Long Island.
Nice state school, good for sciences.
I knew I liked biology.
I wasn't sure if I wanted
to be a bio teacher
or if I wanted to do
something else, maybe.
I didn't realize I could be a scientist
just like I never thought
people like me did science.
But in college I had a really
great professor who said
that we should all try working in a lab.
I did and I realized I really liked it.
So kind of changed my path
from wanting to be a science teacher
into maybe I can do research instead.
I ended up applying to grad school
and now I'm a
PhD student.
So one of the questions in the chat was,
what's my favorite part of doing science
and being in the lab?
And,
I think my favorite part
is knowing that like
some of the things we do,
you're the first person to ever know that.
Like, you're asking questions
that you don't know what
the answer is going to be
because no one's ever been
able to test it before.
So you're literally the
expert in your field.
So that's super exciting.
And then like, everything's like a puzzle.
Even when things don't work,
you know that there's like
a reason it's not working
and you can kind of figure that out
and learn more about
whatever you're doing.
So if I do a PCR for my research project
and something isn't working
well, did I not add primers?
Is my enzyme bad?
Did I use the wrong temperatures?
So it's just really exciting.
I really like biology.
So Amber has perfectly
segwayed into the next point
we were trying to make is,
what can we use PCR for?
I did not pay you to say
that, but perfect timing.
So there are lots of different
things we can use PCR for.
Sometimes we want to just make more DNA
because maybe we want to
do a genetic engineering.
I wanna clone that gene from
the organism it already is in,
into something else.
So like if you've ever seen
those like fluorescent proteins,
they use them to mark
different types of cells.
That's a gene from a jellyfish
that you amplify with PCR
and then you've put into another organism.
So maybe they put it into a bacteria or
a virus even,
or like mammalian cells.
They have some of those monkeys that glow,
which is wild, but so cool.
Another thing you can use PCR for
is like kind of outside
of the realm of research
more on the law side
is
forensic analysis.
If you watch "CSI" or
"Criminal Minds" or anything,
you might've seen people
looking for DNA samples to see
who is the killer or where
they went next or whatever.
So you can imagine that when
you're like swabbing someone's
soda can you're not
getting that much DNA off,
you getting like individual pieces.
And by using PCR, you can
make more and more of it.
And by making more than
you can go in and say,
okay, what is each letter of that thing?
And by knowing each letter,
then you can start to know,
okay, who is this?
Similarly who is this?
This is one of the ways you
can do paternity testing.
So if you amplify a gene,
maybe let's say for,
I don't know, a hair color
and you amplify it off of the
parent one and parent two.
So the maternal and paternal
parents and off of the child,
you can say, okay, well,
does this gene match
what
the two parents have given them?
Because you know that
humans are diploid.
We have one copy of DNA
from the maternal side
and one copy of DNA from the paternal side
and that's how you get
two copies at the end.
Di-ploid two - I don't know
what ploid means but two of them
I guess, chromosomes, your genomes.
So by knowing,
oh, sorry, I realized
I have a hanging nail.
By
checking that these match
the maternal and paternal
genomes, you can find out,
oh, if this doesn't match
you're probably not the parent
or if this does match,
yeah, you are the parent.
Anything else before I talk
a little bit about viruses?
Is there anyone who
inspires you in your field?
Awesome question.
So you guys might know Rosalind Franklin,
if not, that's totally cool.
That's one of the reasons
actually that I think she's so cool.
So,
James Watson
and,
Charles Crick,
is that his first name?
I'm not sure.
Oh, Watson and Crick discovered
this double helix structure.
And we actually call these base pairs
Watson and Crick pairing
because they figured out
that these two go together
and it makes the shape
and this like revolutionized
the world of biology.
But what we don't usually talk
about is the way they knew
that it was the structure was
because this female scientist
called Roslyn Franklin had done
x-ray crystallography.
Basically she took this molecule
like down the middle like this
and shot x-rays through it
and it made this pattern.
You can see how it's
kind of like the spokes
than the outside.
And she said, well, one
of the ways you could get
that pattern is with a double helix.
And her data helped Watson
and Crick figure out
that structure.
Oh, someone just said, oh my God
but they're listening to a podcast.
I was like, yeah,
they figured out the structure.
And,
you don't ever really hear about her
because especially at that time
there were so few female scientists
and they were kind of like, okay,
well, these boys probably figured it out.
And the new Mars rover actually
has an instrument on it
called Rosalind Franklin
because it's looking for life
or signs of life on Mars.
And that's just so cool.
She's like this not
super well-known person
and she really revolutionized science.
So Elizabeth says that they
did a whole study last year
or in their first bio class,
on DNA structure, the double helix.
Super cool, I'm so glad
more people are learning
about Rosalind Franklin.
And then there were like
[indistinct] answers like my PI.
Someone just laughed at me.
But like, yeah they're
new - trying something
for the first time.
My previous PI was
actually, just super cool.
Oh yes, Odaelys says it's
the person who runs the lab.
My previous PI was like,
this awesome woman scientist.
And we go into a like
a high safety level lab
to work with tuberculosis.
And she was like fully seven
and a half months pregnant
like suited up, going into work with TB.
And I just thought that was super cool.
Who is the craziest person
in my academic family tree?
I don't know.
Let me think.
My tree is really small still.
I've only been in like two labs.
So I don't really have someone.
I guess in undergrad
one of the grad students
let me eat a liquid
nitrogen frozen saltine,
that was really cool.
Like smoke comes out
of your nose and mouth
and we did this like at night
after all the grownups had gone home.
So like kind of a secret, but super cool.
So yeah, I guess by that definition,
Eric from my previous lab.
And I'm just gonna make a quick
plug for RockEDU real quick.
They do the science outreach here.
Odaelys is like one of
the pillars of the team.
And so hopefully when the pandemic's over,
y'all can come to campus
and like load your own gels
and image them and they do awesome work.
If you're really interested in science
and you wanna be a part of
maybe some summer programs,
things like that, you can
check out the RockEDU pages
for LAB Jumpstart
on,
Odaelys has linked
everything, that's awesome.
And the summer science
research program, SSRT,
reach out.
And if you have any questions,
I will pop my email in the chat.
Oops, I spelled my name wrong.
Yeah, that's how I spell my name.
And,
oh, I only emailed it, I
only put it to one person,
I am so sorry.
I'm still not very good at Zoom, yeah.
Anything you wanna ask, anything?
Yeah, I'll answer pretty
quickly, no pressure.
Definitely check out the RockEDU things,
those are awesome programs.
Yeah, I don't wanna hold you too long
'cause y'all have something else.
- [Odaelys] I echo that.
Thank you Kathryn.
So yeah, like she mentioned
RockEDU Science Outreach Program.
This is our alternatives to be in virtual.
Usually we have our lab
experiences where your teacher
can actually bring
everyone to our laboratory
and you do exactly what
Kathryn just showed you.
Hopefully by next year we can do so again.
So hopefully teachers
looking out for those emails
or she can sign up and bring everyone in.
In the meantime, you
can check out our page.
We do have research programs.
Those applications are closed for the year
but they open again in the
end of the fall semester.
So around October, September,
lookout for applications
for those research programs
if you're interested in doing
something more full-time in science.
We try to do little things on and off,
but you have to keep checking
our website regularly to see
like what we have going on.
You can sign up for our newsletter
and we can give
announcements for new things
that we have going on for students.
- [Jeanne] Hey guys,
let's altogether say thank you to Kathryn
and RockEDU for this amazing presentation.
Guys, you can put the
clap icon in your window
or you can actually
open your mic and clap,
that would be great.
Kathryn, thank you very much,
that was like really great.
And hopefully I'll get
a recording of this.
So when we actually get to the topic,
I'm sure it's very useful
to us to rewatch the video
because you know, students
will be able to understand much
more, although I know they
gained a lot of understanding
today. Okay, thank you very much.
This is awesome.
- [Teacher] Bye-bye everyone.
Guys, enjoy your weekend.
Remember we're not meeting tomorrow, okay?
- [Odaelys] And enjoy the weather today.
- [Teacher] Yes, yes, get outside guys.
- [Student] Thank you.
- [Student] Thank you so much.